OK.
It's time.
I'm going to try to bring some levity in very
serious times to you during the voice mail
segment.
The voice mail number, of course, is 2 1 9
2.
David P..
Here is an old folk who is telling me, David,
there are old folks who wash.
Watch your show.
Take a listen.
Hey, David.
Please don't see you on your show that old
folks home watch your show cause we're all
souls who we watch your show every day.
Right.
Thanks, David.
Bye.
Yeah.
No, listen, what what I said was it is disproportionately
old folks that are watching Fox News.
And we have more younger folks that watch
our show.
But of course, I know we have people of all
ages who watch our show.
We appreciate everybody.
I'm glad that the old folks in the audience
are demanding recognition.
We actually have we have a big a big supporter
of the show who's in his 90s.
He lives here in the Boston area.
Great guy.
And has been a supporter for years and a week.
We we know about it.
We love the old folks.
We love the poorly educated.
We love the well-educated.
We love the old folks.
We love the young folks.
We love the Americans.
We love the non-Americans.
It's all it's all happening here.
But my point was it's disproportionately old
folks watching Fox News.
Not that there are no old folks watching the
David Packman show.
We have a very interesting bonus show for
you today, which I hope you will watch by
grabbing a membership at Join Packman dot
com.
There is we've wondered what happens if a
Corona virus patient refuses to quarantine.
We now know deputies are surrounding his house
to force him to quarantine.
Number two, Planet Fitness is offering free
at home workout classes via livestream.
This issue of keeping an exercise program
during this crisis is an important one.
And we'll talk about it.
And then lastly, these tennis Tennessee brothers
who bought thousands of bottles of hand sanitizer
to be price gouging with.
Now they say they are sorry, but what's happening
with the hand sanitizer?
That's the question.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a member
at Join Packman Mincome or a patron at Patry
Uncommented Slash Day Dipak.